The oldest person to have ever lived was a
French woman, Jeanne Calment, who lived to
the age of 122 years and 164 days.
As modern medicine and living standards improve
so does our life expectancy, but will the
day soon come when life has no cap?
Some scientists believe it to be much more
than science fiction.
To understand how humans can live forever,
we first need to understand what ageing actually
is.
A lot of people think ageing is a very complex
process, but it’s really quite simple.
Ageing is basically a side effect of being
alive, all of our bodies’ normal day-to-day
processes such as breathing, moving and digesting
food, gradually cause wear and tear on our
cells.
And after a certain amount of wear and tear,
our cells die, causing permanent damage to
our bodies.
Our bodies can only take so much of this cell
damage, so eventually, we die.
Think of your body like a car, driving it
around causes unavoidable wear and tear to
all of its components, until one day it gives
up and refuses to start.
Unless you perform regular maintenance on
it such as changing the oil or even replacing
entire parts.
Some revolutionary scientists have taken this
same mechanical view on the human body and
believe that with regular maintenance and
even replacing damaged organs, we can keep
our bodies running smoothly indefinitely.
In 2011 surgeons in Sweden performed the world’s
first organ transplant using a synthetic organ
that was grown in a lab.
The organ was grown by London scientists in
just a few days.
But most importantly the synthetic windpipe
was grown using the patients own DNA, meaning
there was no chance of the body rejecting
the new organ.
The 36-year-old cancer patient is now doing
fine after the transplant.
Scientists are now working on doing the same
thing with complex organs such as hearts and
lungs and they predict that in less than 10
years any organ will be able to be grown in
a lab on demand in unlimited quantities without
the need for donors.
But immortality could potentially manifest
itself in many ways.
Biogerontologist Marios Kyriazis believes
that immortality is not an if but a when,
he theorises that immortality is an inevitable
consequence of evolution.
His theory states that through evolution the
human brain will one day become so complex
it will be capable of sustaining our bodies
for an indefinite amount of time.
By slowing down the ageing process and stopping
it completely when the body is fully-grown.
But evolution is a an awfully slow process,
if you’re looking for a more immediate solution
to eternal youth you may be surprised to hear
there’s a lot more research going on in
this field than you might imagine.
In 2005 a british scientist named Aubrey de
Grey setup a research foundation called SENS,
which stands for “Strategies for Engineered
Negligible Senescence”.
The aim of SENS is to research and develop
a diverse range of regenerative medical therapies,
to not only stop the ageing process in humans
but also reverse it.
Aubrey believes that death is not an inevitability
but merely a disease, which can be cured with
the correct medical treatment.
In order to lengthen our lives we simply have
to extend the length of our telomeres, which
are caps at the ends of our DNA that shorten
as we age leading to the breakdown of cells.
The answer is simple, if we can develop a
pill to lengthen our telomeres we can stop
and even reverse the ageing process.
Aubrey believes that we will have realistic
age-preventative medicine available to us
in as little as 25 years and that the first
person who will live to 1,000 yeas old has
already been born.
But Aubrey de Grey isn’t the only scientist
interested in living forever.
Scientist and director of engineering at Google
Ray Kurzweil is a prominent futurist and has
accurately predicted many of today’s advanced
technologies years in advance.
Because our understanding of genes and computer
technology is accelerating at an incredible
rate, Ray made a bold prediction.
That in just 20 years time humans will have
developed super advanced microscopic nano
bots that will be able to enter our bodies
in their millions and perform the same jobs
as our blood cells but a thousand times more
effectively, keeping our bodies 100% infection
free and instantly repairing any damaged cells.
Enabling us to live indefinitely and even
reverse ageing.
But Ray predicts that this is not all that
nanotechnology will be able to achieve in
the very near future, he predicts within 25
years we will be able to use nanotechnology
to modify our bodies and obtain superhuman
powers.
For example we will be able to go scuba-diving
for hours without oxygen.
We will be able to extend our mental capacities
to such an extent we will be able to write
books within minutes.
And in our daily lives, hologram like figures
will pop into our brain to explain what’s
happening.
The potentials for nanotechnology are limitless
and many scientists agree that at our current
rate of technological advancement it won’t
be long before nanotechnology and nano bots
are part of our everyday lives.
Changing the way and for how long we live
our lives.
But if all else fails you can always freeze
your body after you die and hope that sometime
in the future scientists will be able to revive
your frozen cadaver and bring you back to
life.
This is called cryonics, you may have only
seen it in films but it’s actually a real
science.
The process involves refrigerating the body
in liquid nitrogen and replacing the blood
with a cryo-protectant fluid to prevent ice
crystals forming inside the body and damaging
the cells.
The body is then suspended upside down in
giant steel container so the head stays the
coldest, and the temperature is lowered to
minus
196 centigrade.
There are currently over 250 bodies preserved
in this way, waiting for science to revive
them and more than 1,000 living people have
signed up for the procedure.
But it doesn’t come cheap, it costs around
$200,000 for a full-body preservation.
Although you can get just your head preserved
for slightly cheaper, in the hope that one
day science will be advanced enough to connect
your head to another body and bring it back
to life with all your memories preserved.
All this talk of immortality is very exciting,
and may be a lot closer than you think.
But what will happen when a certain portion
of humanity refuses to die?
It’s commonly a topic of heated debate.
Overpopulation is already a global issue,
until we are able to find other planets to
inhabit, the unfortunate truth remains that
we need people to die.
Earth can only support so many people.
But that’s not the only problem.
1% of the world’s population own 50% of
the world’s wealth, and if those few people
refuse to die there won’t be any more wealth
distribution, they will only continue to further
monopolise the global market and the rich
will become richer whilst the poor grow poorer.
Another caveat is the retirement age would
shoot up to hundreds of years.
This is fine for the ambitious few who seek
premium jobs and luxurious lifestyles, but
imagine being forced to work for over 1,000
years flipping burgers at McDonalds.
In an immortal society criminal punishments
would become greatly devalued. 30 years behind
bars in nothing for someone with a lifespan
of thousands of years, and with such a lousy
deterrent crime could increase dramatically.
Also with the value of ones life being so
much higher death sentences wouldn’t be
given out so frequently and we may have to
invest heavily in rehabilitation techniques
or even brainwashing techniques to keep the
unruly side of society under control.
But there are benefits to an immortal population.
We will finally be able to send people to
explore other planets, that would otherwise
take more than a lifetime to reach.
Also those Einstein-like people among us who
have brilliant minds will live forever and
so their knowledge will continue to grow and
contribute to the global knowledge bank.
As a result, human knowledge will grow at
an unprecedented rate.
Society will advance and develop new technologies
at an astonishing, ever-increasing rate.